And now the old scout master
On the Wednesday at summer camp is kind of an open day for troops to go do their own
thing And some of them go into Yellowstone for the day, which is what we did. You will
be in uniform the whole time. Well, do I have to wear the hat? Well, yes, of course
you have to wear the hat as part of the uniform. There's been some some questions, especially
by some of them that are getting to be of that age where they feel like it's
dorky And I mean the younger guys love it. They're like, Okay, put my uniform,
no problem. But the 13 year olds are like, Really, Yeah, Yeah, Yeah. So they wore
their uniform to Yellowstone And while they were walking around on the board
walks around Old Faithful, these guys were like minor celebrities. Everybody
was stopping to take pictures of them. There was one patrol that was kind of
milling around trying to decide what they were going to do next, And this
group of Japanese tourists- they were all like high school girls And they came
up to me and they asked if they could get their picture taken with the Scouts. And
I just turned to the scouts and said: Is that okay with you guys? And the
patrol leader looked at me like I was the stupidest guy on the planet and said,
Well, yeah. So they got their picture taken with them And everywhere they
went, people were, you know, turning and taking pictures of them, And so, on the
drive back to camp, I said, You know, those experiences you would not
have if you weren't wearing a uniform And you wouldn't have opened the doors
that were open for you guys while we were traveling. And the realization that
girls may actually like the uniform- Right, Yeah, How about that?
It's not as dorky as you think. From a Scoutmaster standpoint, it's
great to have them traveling uniform because you know you'll have people
coming up all the time saying, Hey, it's a couple of your guys over here.
I was like, Okay, you know, were they behaving? They're like, Yeah, they're
doing great, They're just they're having a good time. I was like, Okay, you
know. so it's like, all of a sudden, everybody else in, you know, in Yellowstone,
became, you know, informants for me on what my guys are. Well, it's easier to
keep track of a group that's in uniform And there are things that you may
think twice about doing when you're wearing a scout uniform. So, yes, if
you're in uniform, everybody knows you're a scout, There's a level of
behavior that is acceptable And it will give you pause. And they're like:
Yeah, you know it does. There is what we call. the leash of
this is Clark Green. Let's take a look in the mailbag here. Kurt Huber is with
Troop 415 in Swanee, Georgia, And he wrote to say this. first, I want to
thank you for the link you gave to camping kitchen boxcom. Now, if you
look on the blog at scoutmastercgcom, you'll see a recent post
about camping kitchen boxes, And I featured Kurt's site, camping
kitchen boxcom, And he tells us that this is his hobby business. It
gave quite a bump to my traffic when you mentioned it on your site.
More importantly, I want to thank you for the resource you created
with your website, which I have been reading more and more of
lately. I've been listening to the podcast since April And, as an
assistant scout master, I'm always learning something new or
at least being pointed in the right direction. Thanks again.
Thank you, Kurt, for getting in touch and make sure to check out
camping kitchen boxcom. Interesting take on a patrol box. This
is the Monday of Labor Day weekend And I'm sure everyone has
been taking a deep breath from all their summer activities and
gearing up for this next year of scouting. In order to get you
ready for that, in this podcast we're going to have our next
installment of the Colorado experiment with our friend
Arlan Ward, And I'm sure you're looking forward to hearing
that. And while we're talking about Arlan, this Sunday, September
7th, from nine to 10 Eastern Standard Time, Arlan will be
talking with Derek Hansen, who is the author of a book called
The Ultimate Hang That is an illustrated guide to hammock
camping. Derek is also a scouter, as well as one of the hammock
camping tribe out there, And he will have some great
information, not only just about hammock camping in general,
but how it can be used in scouts, And so I'm really
looking forward to listening to Derek again at scoutcircleorg
between nine and 10pm Eastern Standard Time this Sunday,
September 7th. So we're going to catch you up with what's
happening out there with Troop 17 in Colorado. If you're a fairly
new listener and you're not familiar with the Colorado
experiment, we'll catch up a little bit, But that's going
to take up the rest of the podcast. So let's get started,
shall we?
And now our next episode of the Colorado experiment.
Yeah, it's time for us to talk to our buddy, Arlan Ward, And
Arlan is out in Thornton, Colorado. You'll remember, if
you've been listening to the podcast for a little while,
that we've had several installments of the Colorado
experiment. We're kind of tracking Arlan's experience
with a brand new scout troop. He started out as a cub
master And, as his son was getting ready to transition
into scouts, decided somehow that it might be a good idea
to start a new scout troop. we've talked about that
whole process. go back and check those podcasts out if
you want to catch up on the whole story. But here we
are in just the very end of August 2013.. And we're going
to catch up on what Arlan's new troop has been doing
for the summer. How are you doing, Arlan?
I'm doing great. It's been a wonderful summer.
Give us a little rundown of your summer schedule.
Originally, when we set up the troop, when it was just
the adults talking, we had said: this first summer
we'll probably just have a couple of boys, you know,
maybe four or five or maybe six, And so we figured we
just spend the summer camping on our own. And we
started the troop in April And I think the PLC
meeting in April, they came back to us and said:
look, we want to go to summer camp this summer, See what
you can do. And so we made some phone calls and looked
around and did some investigating on the internet
and found a few that had openings later in the
summer. So we put those in front of the troop and
said: okay, where do you want to go? They decided
they wanted to go to Camp Buffalo Bill in Wyoming
is when I grew up going to, so I was familiar with
it and kind of what was in the area and things like
that. And I'm going to be the cynic for a moment.
You ended up putting these different options out
in front of the boys and they said, Oh, the camp
that you used to go to sounds like a good option.
Did they know that you used to go there? Did you
influence that decision at all? Did you coerce
them at all to make that decision?
You know I had not mentioned to the Scouts at
all that I had gone there, But I- but I knew
enough about the camp, that it was close to
Yellowstone, that we included all of that
information. You know, when we proposed this one
that was a little bit further away, I said:
you know we can, you know we'll leave a day
early and you know, stop on the way up there
and stop on the way back, And I think it did
influence it. but it wasn't that I said, Hey,
this is the one I went to before And I think
you should go there. I think that just kind
of, as adults we have the guile and the
experience to be able to kind of highlight a
decision for the boys that we would like to
see them make. I'm not saying that that is
in and of itself necessarily a wrong thing
to do in every circumstance. Were you, were
you hoping for a certain result, Or was it
just like, eh, it doesn't really matter to
me. I really had hoped for this And I'm
sure that we influenced it along the way-
still their call, I suppose. But but yeah,
we were definitely influencing it. I think
a mentor right is kind of the role of,
of the adult leadership more than than the
manager right. So you know, it's not
that they say you have to do it this
way, But they say you know this, this
looks like a really good way to go about
it. You know, it's not blindly just
throwing the options in front of and
making it make a decision. This is that
really interesting and fascinating
part of working with youth leadership.
Do you just say, Hey, whatever you guys
want to do, or do you kind of triage
the decision making a say: look, you
know, I looked at a lot of different
options. This is the option that I
like the best, or that I think is the
most workable. I think that it's
appropriate to do both things, just
depending on the circumstance
And how complex the question is. I
mean, if you're talking true t-shirts,
there's a thousand different options
out there And it's perfectly okay to
give them all thousand different
options, to give them 15 different
scout camps that are all within a
reasonable driving distance of your
home location. That's a lot, I mean,
because not only is it 15 different
camps but you have to balance. what
is their program, how are we going
to get there? Every one of the camps
have 15 things that you have to take
into account. That becomes a really
complex decision. What we did is work
with the SPL and just made a
spreadsheet that said: Here's where
the camp is, Here's how far it is,
Here's the weeks that they have.
opening Schedule was another one
that you know which week are we
going to go. That just adds more
complexity to the whole thing And
so working with the SPL to kind of
go through it to begin with and
say, you know, look, here's a
list of five or six viable
options. But boy, look at these two,
They really kind of stand out. and
then turn it over to the SPL to go
talk to the, to the troop. It's not
like we just give them a free, for
all of you know, we can go wherever
you want, We can do whatever you
want and we can spend. you know, go
any week that you want, and all
that. You will never make a
decision. See, that's, I think, a
really important thing for people to
get. How do you make this work
where there's a decision making
process going on and what you
describe you know, in looking at
the options and even doing a
spreadsheet of them and working
with the senior patrol leader on
that? because what you've done in
that process is you've given him
the benefit of your experience
and, at the same time, the
moment to be able to teach him.
okay. so if you have this big,
wide field of options, this is how
you begin triaging it and
figuring out what is actually
workable. That's a pretty
important thing for scout
masters to be able to do. We
think sometimes that the way
we're going to work with youth
leadership is kind of the way we
work with a light switch: We're
either going to turn it on and let
them make any decision that they
think they should make or we're
going to turn it off and make
their decisions for them. What
I'm hearing from you is it's
more of a collaborative
enterprise than it is just one
way or the other. Yeah,
absolutely, And it was
initiated from their side to
start with. The PLC came to me
and the committee chair and
we really want to go to summer
camp this year and we kind of
said, well, let's see what's
out there And then we'll come
back and we'll we'll get you
some of the options. You know.
next year, you know, with
more time, it's possible that
we would have, you know, SPL
involved in that process of
gathering information on the
different camps and things
like that- Another aspect of
this whole planning and
decision making process. So
let's say that you're looking
at next summer and they say
we want to do exactly what
we did last summer. Do you
have a problem with that?
No, I would like to see him
go somewhere else. You know,
we were sitting around the
campfire and our campsite
and said: you know, what did
you like about this camp?
What didn't you like? What
would you like to see us do
next time? You know, if
they wanted to do it, I
like one of the last
camps. So you know you
wouldn't create a rule for
them. You can't do anything
that you did last year. If
the SPL felt that strong
about it, you know he could
get it through- the PLC, I
imagine, but I don't. you
know, every time that I've
ever felt the need to
decree something, I've really
had to step back and say: is
that really something that
needs to be, you know,
decreed? Do I need to step
in and say you will and you
won't, and all of that?
Well, the other thing is the
kind of flexibility that
you had in being able to
say, oh, they want to go
to summer camp. Well, we
should really try and make
that happen. That must
have been pretty energizing
when you heard that from
them. It was, but it
was. there were some big
hurdles from the adult side
that we had to get through.
So there was some scrambling
that happened on our side.
but you know, if it had
been impossible, then I
suppose we'd probably have
to have a part of
conversations about it,
But it wasn't impossible.
Things that you know you
normally have spread out over
a few months. We were
doing like on top of each
other
And then you had a
Petrollers Council weekend
and the kind of like a
training and planning
weekend
In broad strokes. the
Weather Troop is organized
on schedule is that- and
the new troop leadership
takes over in August.
And the month of August
we don't actually have
troop meetings but we
have a PLC camp out where
the new, new elected leaders
and their- you know the
appointed positions and all
of that that they go
on a camp out just for
them And we'd go through
the troop leader training.
but we went through that
training with them. And
then also they planned
out the year in broad strokes,
as far as this is what
we're going to do on this
weekend, in these months,
And they put together
the schedule for the next
12 months up to and
including the next PLC camp
out, which will be next
August.
And what are you looking
at right now for numbers?
Yeah, we're 19 scouts.
Do you have your meeting
place?
We do.
You'll start meeting
pretty much concurrently
with the school year.
Yeah, So the idea is
that you know, summer
camp is. in the summer camp
you elect new troop leaders
and sometime in August
you have this PLC training
annual planning camp out.
We kicked off this next
year with a court of honor
Worked out great,
They did a great job with it-
Tried, as we've gone through
and talked to these several
times, to have the same
three questions for you
And I don't. I don't think
we've succeeded
in having exactly the same
three questions. But in the
spirit of the three
questions, since we last
spoke, what
have you seen that you
didn't expect to see
or you found
kind of interesting or
maybe even challenging about
being a new scoutmaster and
having a brand new troop?
The thing that I didn't expect
to see that has happened
is how readily
they take on the roles
of leadership.
I sat down with the SPL
like: so what's the plan
for the court of honor?
And I looked at him and I said:
well, you know, you can
set it up however you want,
You know, and he looks at me,
goes. well, am I doing it
or are you doing it?
I said, well, it's your court
of honor, You do it,
You know, I said. I said
you just leave me with a couple
of minutes at the end,
You know, and check in hands,
And that's really all I got to do.
I said other than that
you can, you can put it
together however you want.
And you know his guys,
they huddled together and they're
like, well, you know, I can put
together a program. and
those other persons said, OK,
you know, are we going to eat
first, Are we going to do the
court of honor first?
And what about? you know
the pictures that we have from
the stuff that we've done since
since April till now?
Maybe we could do a slideshow.
And you know, it came together,
just you know, in the course
of about 15 minutes, of
them having a plan for what was
going to go on.
You know, my part was
to remind them. you know
where the court of honor was on
Monday and it was Thursday
And I hadn't seen anything
communicated to, you know,
troop-wide to anybody
Reminded the SPL. I said
a lot of these email addresses
that you have are parents
at work And if you don't tell
them by Friday, they're not
going to see it until Monday
And it's going to be too late,
you know, and just kind of
prodding and making sure
that the communication part
happened. But you know,
they planned it, they executed
it, They emceed the whole
thing. You know they did a
great job and talked
through that, not only
who got what rank, but
also kind of explained to
the parents that were in the
room what sort of things
you have to do for that rank.
And I didn't prompt them to
do that, I didn't say that
you had to. And they did a
great job with it, Even did
some recognition for the
adults that had started the
troop and things that
weren't, you know, on my radar
at all. And then I did
my Scout Masters
men at the end that they
berated me endlessly for not
being a minute long and a whole
advancement thing. That's
another thing that really
surprised me.
What surprised you about it?
That they took it on? You and
I have talked in the past
about, you know, having
parents come up. how do you
handle advancement? And you
know I'm not going to sit
down with a checklist and say,
okay, everybody that goes on
this camp is going to do
this and this and this and
this. You know there's
been some parents that were
concerned. They're like, how
are we going to make sure that
they advance? I said, well,
you know, let them take it
on and see where it goes.
And Summer Camp was amazing
for that. I watched
practically every night
some Scout dig out his
book and he would walk over
to his patrol leader and say:
I did this, Can you sign it
off? It was like Prairie Dogs.
Everybody kind of looks at
him and goes what? Oh,
advancement, Yeah, You know.
and and then you know
all of a sudden all the
books are out. you know
you've got patrols huddled
around each other. You know
they're all not only going
through stuff and getting
stuff signed off that they
did, but making plans
for the rest of it.
Well, we need to identify
10 plants. The SPL goes
well. you know there's a
Nature Lodge right down
there And I bet during
free time tomorrow that they
would be more than happy to
work with you guys on how to
identify 10 plants. And then
they went and did it. I mean,
my role in all of this was
just watching it happen
from, you know, 25 feet
away. It was a bit of a
hard sell to the parents.
We're going to rely on
their own interest to define
how fast they advance or
what they choose to do
towards an advancement. But
then the Scouts sounded
like the Scouts made you
look pretty good. It was
surprising to me how, how
much they owned it. But
you know, it's like somebody
lit a fire in summer camp.
You know I, in the future,
any parent that comes to be
concerned about advancement,
you know my advice is going
to be make sure they go to
summer camp, Because it's not
about the merit badges,
classes or anything like
that, It's just being in a
troop for a week with
other Scouts and figuring
it out. you know, looking
around and see how other
Scouts are handling it, and
that it's not this
insurmountable problem. It's
just something to for you
to happen to back your
mind while you're doing
all these other great things.
The. the other question is
is: what would you have
done differently?
Um, well,
it's all right, You don't
have to have one of those,
but maybe there's
something in retrospect
that maybe you would have.
you would have done a
little bit on the. the
whole fluidity of the
schedule thing for the
first few months was
was a bit of an issue.
You know, I think the
communication piece
certainly be better.
The SPL still has not
appointed a scribe, you
know, and I told them.
you know, as long as
you don't do that,
that job is going to
fall to you
And at some point
you need to appoint
somebody to that position
or you just continue
to do all the
communicating.
If it was me, I would have
done it a long time ago.
but yeah, he'll,
he'll hit his,
he'll hit his saturation
point. The third question
is: what do you hope
to see happen over
the next couple of
months or in the
determinant future?
It doesn't have to be
just the next couple
of months.
I would like to see them
get in the groove of
the whole idea of
having meetings to
prepare for the outings
and really owning that
as as patrols,
having patrol leaders
teaching the skills
to their patrols.
A lot of that teaching
happened, or it has
over the last few months,
has been at the
troop level,
because we had some
rather inexperienced
patrol leaders, you know.
So I'd like to see
those patrol leaders
teaching their patrols
more than the SPL
teaching the entire troop.
you know where patrol
leader or somebody
that that patrol leader
tags for it,
is teaching their patrol
that skill.
Now you're talking
five to eight guys
and that's a much easier
to do.
You look at
the number of boys
that are in the troop now,
the number of
second-year weeblers
that are looking
to this troop to
to join.
you know we could
be at 40 by
March.
you know
at which point
it really does
become a problem
to try to do this
at the troop level
And if we can instill
that we are a collection
of patrols
more than we are a troop,
if you can instill that early,
the less of
what problem
we'll have. of growing pains,
I think.
Well, growing pains
are good pains to have,
So sure,
Yeah.
The thing I wanted to mention
was the annual planning.
The SPL kind of took
the scouts and said: OK,
we're going to go over here
and we're going to come up
with an annual plan.
It was like: oh,
you don't want me involved,
I'll sit over here.
It's like you know. fine,
If you want to own it,
you can own it.
That's great,
Say I was flabbergasted.
Schedule that they put together
is more rigorous
in scouting stuff
than I would have done
had I done it.
There's some preparation
that has to go into every one of these,
But that's great
because that gives them
the challenge
and it gives them
questions that they have to ponder.
And one of the things
that you have
that maybe a lot of people
would not have
is a couple of older, experienced scouts
right from the get go.
Oh, yes,
Yeah, and that helps immensely
having these two guys
that are life scouts-
One is 17
and one is may have just turned 17..
They're really only around
for this first year,
But having the benefit
of having them set the tone,
having their previous
scouting experience,
that's been a huge help.
You know, next summer,
when we're electing
new senior patrol leaders,
we're going to go from having
a 17 year old senior patrol leader
to a 14 year old
senior patrol leader,
So it'll be different,
but the tone will have been sad.
Thanks so much for sharing
with us once again
And we'll be in touch again.
We'll see how things are going,
So hopefully there'll be
some great stuff to talk about.
Thanks a lot, Arlen,
You bet.
Hey. thanks so much for listening
to this edition of the Scout Master
podcast, and here's how you
can keep in touch.
You can read the Scout Master
blog at scoutmastercgcom
And, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email.
You can also subscribe
to the Scout Master podcast
on iTunes or access
the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
And you can get details
about how to make that happen
at stitchercom.
You can also experience
the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 4,000 plus followers
at Scout Master blog on Facebook,
Follow Scout Master CG on Twitter
And you can watch us
at our Scout Master CG channel
on YouTube.
And finally, for admittance
to the exclusive
Scout Master CG circle,
search for Scout Master CG
on Google Plus.
If you don't face or tweet
or plus or YouTube,
you can always email me.
Yeah, zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email at
clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
The Scout Master blog
and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
Nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Oh, my goodness.
No, it's just me talking
into a microphone
trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and maybe, you know,
have a little bit of fun
as we do.
And speaking of fun,
here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.